Unreal Engine 5's Blueprint Editor is one of its most powerful tools as this allows
you to create C++ code without actually having to write or know that much about C++ code.
This is achieved by laying down various nodes and then connecting them in a flowchart-like
manner in order to construct game logic or interactivity.
Blueprints can be simple assets that just contain a mesh or a light, or they can be
very complex and even have the ability to call other blueprints within blueprints.
Let's pop over to the editor now and just take a look at these briefly to get a better
understanding of what we're working with here.
I'm going to hit Control Space on my keyboard and then I'm going to make sure that I have
my Blueprint classes here.
These are all the various blueprints that are in this particular project.
For example, I can pull out this Blueprint ceiling light here and let me just pull this
up and we can see here that this is a light.
If I come over here, you can see I have a brightness and I have a color property here
that I can adjust and I have a source radius.
Now, I'm going to select this and I'm going to hit Control E on my keyboard and that's
going to open up the Blueprint Editor.
This is our Blueprint Editor.
The Blueprint Editor has three main parts.
There's a viewport which represents our visual part.
If our Blueprint needs to have some type of visual component, our viewport is where we
position it and make sure that everything is the way we want it to look.
Then we have the Event Graph and the Construction Script.
The Event Graph is functional when we press play.
When I press the play button right here, things that happen inside of the Event Graph will
fire off.
The Construction Script, on the other hand, this works when I'm inside of the Editor.
The Construction Script, when I go ahead and set something like the brightness here, notice
that the Construction Script is firing off.
That's again because we're telling that Construction Script to change the brightness and we do that
inside of our Event Graph.
As I come through here, we're going to have a bunch of different things that I can do.
Here's another Blueprint for Echo.
This will take just a second.
I think it hasn't been compiled.
Give us just a second here.
Did I lose it?
I'll just bring it right there.
There we go.
Here is our Echo.
If I was to hit Ctrl E on this, we're going to notice a much more complicated Blueprint
here.
We're going to take a look at the Open.
It looks like I actually opened up the demo display.
Let me close that.
I meant to grab her and hit Ctrl E. There we go.
Here's her Construction Script.
It's setting up her hair.
It looks like here's the Event Graph.
It looks like it's doing some stuff with the hair.
Here's our viewport.
Then over here, we have our components, which contain different things like there's stuff
for her hair.
A lot of stuff around her hair on this.
Again, the Blueprint Editor is a super, super powerful tool that allows anybody, whether
they be a level designer, a technical artist, regular artist, or even just a regular designer,
the ability to block out code or experiment in ways that just haven't been possible before.